Fabien : Bonjour YouTube et petit peuple des internet!
Je suis aujourd'hui avec le Grand, l'Unique, le Seul mais aussi le multiple : SuperFlame
Voix d'Homer: Salut tout le monde!
F: Je vous présente cet ovni de Youtube
P'tain c'est magnifique... tu imites le mec qui parle pas
SF : Moi je suis pas trop dans la spontanéité, je suis toujours tout seul facecam
F : C'est ça, ben je peux partir
SF: Vas-y barre-toi rentre chez toi... non non, parce que tu vas le laisser, tu vas l'mettre, et tu vas...
F: C'est ça et le pire c'est que je reste dans le champs
SF: Je prends le contrôle de cette vidéo,  abonnez-vous à ma chaine, au revoir
F: Si tu veux je te donne un temps d'imitation, tu peux dire ce que tu veux comme tu veux, et si tu veux
SF: D'accord [JP Pernaut: ] Madame,  Monsieur, bonjour, c'est Jean-Pierre Pernaut
Bienvenue dans ce 13h , aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans une vidéo de Fabien Olicard, reportage:
[Voix journaliste: ] Nous nous trouvons actuellement en région parisienne, dans les locaux de Fabien Olicard,
mentaliste très connu, comme nous le confirme Josette, sa grand-mère :
[Voix grand-mère] Ah bah le petit Fabien depuis qu'il est tout p'tit il fait des trucs bizarres
Une fois il m'a mentalisé pour que je lui donne deux fois de l'argent de poche, l'enfoiré !
[Journaliste : ] Simpson a décidé de témoigner également :
[Homer : ] Fabien Olicard c'est un mec super sympa mais j'aimerais bien qu'il me mentalise pour qu'il m'apprenne à manger
encore plus de donuts que je peux en manger actuellement et aussi est-ce qu'il peut me
mentaliser pour que je puisse changer les choses en bière?
F: Bravo!  (SF: Merci!) Bravo, tout le public du studio t'applaudit!
C'est beau, c'est précis, maintenant tu vas nous apprendre à faire une ou deux voix
et moi je vais me mettre à votre place, je vais essayer de le faire même temps
comme ça vous pourrez pas être plus ridicule que moi... vous voyez le délire ou pas, parce que en plus de ça je vais être
ridicule doublement parce que je vais me sentir jugé
tu vois, par le maestro... SF [Voix de Maestro : ] et en parlant de Maestro, c'est un personnage joué par Roger Carel,
qui a d'ailleurs arrêté sa carrière récemment mais qui est un homme exceptionnel
donc déjà ce que je peux proposer
c'est tout simplement la voix des journalistes, la voix off des journalistes de reportage
parce que ça c'est vachement plus de la prosodie qu'une voix en elle-même
la prosodie, c'est un peu la mélodie de la voix, c'est la manière de parler tu peux essayer de reproduire cette mélodie mais en parlant.
Avant de faire ça, on va déjà essayer de la reproduire ensemble en faisant des la : lala la la
- F : lala la la. - SF:  lala la la.
- F : la la la la. - SF:  lala lala la la la-la. - F : lala lala lala la la.
SF : He bah ça, les espèces de mélodies que tu peux venir plaquer sur des textes genre en une phrase,  "j'adore les chats" avec l'intonation
journalistique ça donne " j'adore les chats"
F : Ah putain... C'est hyper varié...  - SF : tatatata
F : j'adore les chats SF : j'adore les chats F :  j'adore les chats
SF : Essaie d'étirer les syllabes sur la fin, (F : "j'adore les chats") , il faut vraiment dramatiser ton discours même si c'est un truc joyeux
il faut que ce soit dramatique. - F : il semblerait que les personnes regardant cette vidéo
ait envie de la liker et si c'est bien le cas, ils seront invités à aller découvrir la chaîne
de SuperFlamme en cliquant sur le lien sur la description
SF : C'est vraiment pas mal mais va falloir étirer un peu plus les syllabes et dramatiser, faut ajouter plus de nuances... - F : J'suis en stress j'te jure! J'ai trop de stress!
SF : C'est vrai? Au niveau de la mélodie faut faire haut-bas, vraiment haut-bas haut-bas !
ta!-ta!-ta!-ta! ta, ta, tata. SF :  il paraît que lorsque l'on clique sur le lien dans la description
on est redirigé vers la chaîne de Superflame. - F : Attends, tu peux le refaire un coup? [Journaliste : ] la nouvelle vient de tomber
il paraît que lorsque l'on clique sur le lien dans la description on atterrit sur une vidéo de Superflame. - F : J'étais pas mal là - Ouais
F : C'est parti pour les jumeaux
SF : c'est effrayant ça!  c'est parti pour les jumeaux.  Il vient de proposer Igor et Grichka Bogdanoff, alors écoutes,
on choisit qui? SF : Alors déjà on va faire une voix un peu serrée,
qui n'est pas sans rappeler celle de Jean Pierre Pernaut, (F : c'est ce que j'allais dire) d'ailleurs j'ai "unlock" leurs voix en imitant Pernaut
F : D'accord, le mec c'est un jeu vidéo dans sa tête! SF : Non mais  je réfléchis en termes
de voix qui permettent d'en débloquer d'autres parce qu'en fait
la voix des Bogdanoff c'est juste la voix de Jean Pierre Pernaut,  mais en vachement plus punchy et
plus aigue (F : Okay)  [ JP Pernaut : ] Jean pierre Pernaut est comme ça et Igor et Grichka [Bogdanoff], ils sont un petit peu au dessus -  F : [Essai] je souhaite parler...
SF: c'est pas mal, faut faire descendre le son
comme si t'avais une espèce de balle de tennis à ce niveau là
F : une balle de tennis , une balle de tennis à ce niveau là... Oooh, j'ai plus Phillipe  Bouvard !
SF: Ouai c'est vrai qu'il y a un côté Phillipe Bouvard
SF: essaie de gonfler tes joues en parlant cette fois comme Droopy
bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour pas mal après ce qui est bien avec cette imitation
FB: c'est le pas mal pas mal de ma mère quand j'avais cinq ans je faisais un gros que j'ai gribouillis sur un dessin
FB: c'est pas mal. SF: c'est qui ça c'est... ah c'est toi
F: bonjour Igor. SF: bonjour Igor. F: bonjour Igor
F: Bonjour Igor
SF: bonjour Igor. F: bonjour Igor bonjour Igor, bonjour Grichka. Bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans temps X. ça le fait
F: Toi oui mais moi je vais faire Maïté
[rire]
SF: Bonjour Igor
F: Bonjour Igor, Bonjour Grichka... et bienvenue à cette nouvelle émission
SF: émissions culinaires et bienvenue dans space cuisine la cuisine de l'espace
SF: on serre la gorge pour parler un peu comme ça, on gonfle un peu les joues pour avoir un son un peu plus rond, on relève légèrement la langue
et on rajoute d'énergie comme si on criait on passe donc de Jean Pierre Pernaut à un Igor et Grichka Bogdanoff
voilà allez y, c'est assez simple, sauf pour Fabien. Je peux spontanément prendre des voix
et je sais que c'est assez, assez rare pour en avoir discuté avec d'autres imitateur parce qu'il ya quelques années j'étais
invité au festival national de l'imitation à Carcassonne et j'avais discuté avec d'autres imitateurs ils m'avaient dit mais toi c'est ouf tu peux basculer
de ta voix normale à une autre voix mais en une fraction de seconde alors que ils ont besoin de se préparer à rentrer dans le personnage
il commence à faire des essais et tout
et moi je peux spontanément changer ma voix et c'est assez effrayant pour la plupart des gens F: oui toi tu compenses
de ce que je t'ai vu faire t'as pas besoin de compenser avec toutes la gestuelle.
c'était un Sarkozy que vous avez vu. SF: quand j’ai déjà entendu une voix ou que j'ai souvent été exposé à une voix
je peux la reconnaître n'importe quand quand elles resurgi
typiquement je me souviens il y a quelques temps sur sur l'émission de guillaume pley ils avaient piégé Andy Raconte
et j'ai reconnu, il y a Kevin Tran de la chaîne du rire jaune qui avait appelé Andy Raconte
il a parlé pendant 10 secondes et je savais que c'était lui qui était en train de parler d'accord j'ai envoyé un petit message sur
twitter tu es en train de passer sur NRJ , machin, machin. bon il a pas répondu parce qu'il était au téléphone
et s'est avéré que c'était lui
mais ce genre en 10 secondes chronos je savais que c'étais lui au téléphone parce que j'ai reconnu sa manière de parler en fait d'accord instantanément
et je pense
un concept que j'essaie de développer c'est un peu le
concept d'empreinte vocale je pense que tout le monde a une empreinte une empreinte vocale un peu comme on a tous une empreinte digitale
et que cette empreinte vocale est composé de diverses éléments
donc la prosodie la manière de parler la voix on est le même le vocabulaire un truc comme ça
après j'ai pas une petite technique quand je veux volontairement faire une voix
qui est de me dire
plus je connais de voix plus je peux potentiellement en faire d'autres parce que je raisonne vraiment un
peu comme si c'était une espèce de toiles d'araignées ou des voix que je peux maîtriser F: oui je comprends
SF: je raisonne en termes de est ce que ses proches
d'une imitation que je sais déjà faire par exemple la voix de Jean Pierre Pernaut comme on l'a fait en
introduction de cette vidéo est très proche de la voix des frères Bogdanoff et du coup
dès l'instant où j'ai été capable de maîtriser la voix de jean pierre pernaut
j'ai eu assez rapidement le déclic de me dire mais attend la voix des frères Bogdanoff c'est un peu le même genre de voix
un peu étouffé sauf qu'il y a un coté un peu plus punchy F: quand tu prenais la référence de la toile d'araignée je vois
vraiment la visualisation de toi au centre par exemple avec un Pernaut là et là du coup t'arrive à avoir un Bogdanov ici
en incrémentant un petit détail en plus SF: voilà c'est typiquement ça exactement ça F: c'est très clair
et par exemple la voix de Roger Carel que vous entendez à l'heure actuelle
c'est le mec qui fait la voix d'Astérix
donc là sur entrain d'imiter sa voix quand il parle normalement et Astérix c'est la même chose mais en un peu plus nasillard
F: ah c'est ça
SF: et je raisonne vraiment comme ça et pour moi, il y a vraiment un espèce de travail de comédien en plus de simplement
l'imitateur changement de voix et ouais...
spontanément quand je prends une voix de gosse je suis un peu plus jovial et je bouge
J'ai les yeux qui s'équarquillent euh c'est trop cool la vie! tu vois, des trucs comme ça...
F: Cool! Super intéressant! Merci, pour tout ça. C'est un plaisir, un plaisir.
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo checker sa chaîne en
descriptions un petit like un petit abonnement à moi aussi si ce n'est pas déjà fait
SF(voix simpson): abonnez vous à sa chaînes et à la mienne gros bisous mouah
SF(voix Grichka): mesdames et messieurs nous observons actuellement deux particules d'abonnement qui viennent du cosmos elle viennent d'arriver sur votre ordinateur
ou d'un smartphone tout dépend du support que vous utilisez appuyez dessus et vous serez redirigé vers une aventure
absolument extraordinaire tout à fait Igor